if you can agree on four things prior to
marriage the probability of you still
being married 40 years later is very
high if you can agree on your money if
you can agree on kids how many we going
to have how we going to raise them
In-laws crazi in the family cuz there
every family's got crazy in it and if
you don't think there's crazy in your
family it means it's you and so um and
then the fourth is be in agreement on
religion if we're going to be atheists
then let's be in agreement about that if
we're going to be Christian there's very
few cross religion marriages end up
making it long term because again it's a
value system thing it's how you live
your life your decision-making Paradigm
comes out of your value system